day one in the nation's top job and
anthony albanese has promised unity and
optimism to australian voters he'll hit
the ground running boarding a flight to
tokyo on monday for his first official
meeting as the nation's leader
obviously the quad leaders meeting is an
absolute priority for australia and it
is it enables us to send a message to
the world
that
we
have there is a change of government
there will be some changes in policy
particularly with regard to climate
change and our engagement uh with the
world
on those issues
this election race was run on
personality over policy
powerful swings left the conservative
coalition party without the numbers to
hold on to government as voters drove
the liberals out of key marginal seats
the outgoing prime minister returned to
his church conceding his party misjudged
the electorate
you've given us a great foundation from
which
we could
walk
what has been a very difficult walk
i've got to tell you
over the last almost four years
but at the last election
we
really understood that it was for such a
time as this
and now we both know it was for such a
time as that
new to parliament are at least nine
high-profile female independents the
group campaigned for more action on
climate change and legislating a federal
integrity commission to investigate
political corruption
that appealed to voters who abandoned
candidates from scott morrison's party
in blue ribbon seats lovely to see the
independence i think the real change and
a step forward and for the environment i
feel like maybe now is the time for us
to to do something different and if we
can get action on climate change then
that's going to be quite exciting this
election has seen a seismic shift in
australia's political landscape not only
is there a new group of independents
demanding greater action on climate
change the greens party is also hailing
it as their best result ever with
dramatic gains in both the lower and the
upper house
the postal vote is still being counted
and some seats remain undecided but the
labour party has vowed to get down to
business with a more united approach to
federal politics sarah clark al jazeera
sydney